what is up guys my name is Jonah welcome
to episode 19 of 30 game programming in
Java all righty sir so it is the new
year this is the first episode of Java
game programming 3d Java game
programming in Java weight 3d game
programming in Java in 2012 so yeah
that's pretty that's pretty huge I took
a break and I actually took a break to
recover as well I would suppose that
this episode out on Sunday but I just
wasn't feeling well because I went
through a course of antibiotics like how
high-powered antibiotics like Reza Fame
so that was yeah well you know it was
injected and stuff so I had a favor and
stuff like that but I should be good now
I had basically a really mild bronchitis
so yeah
but I'm feeling a lot better now which
is awesome and yeah so that's why I
didn't have that episode out by Sunday
but enough of me apologizing let's just
get on with this again so last time we
had this and actually more specifically
what is this this more specifically we
actually had with our spring class this
sort of what we achieved and if we uh we
try this out so we had this little thing
which sort of worked and like basically
I don't want you guys to think cuz I
know that a lot of you guys were like
hey check this out I made like a I don't
know like a building out of this like
this was just basically me showing you
guys how to put pixels on to the screen
in the form of wall this is a horrible
way to do this as you can see we've got
basically two walls and we've lost half
of our frames for seconds like that's
that's bad so this is just a basic way
of how we're sort of going to put pixels
to the screen now what we're going to do
is is actually do it in a more
performance friendly way and before we
do that actually speaking of performance
I'm just okay this is just getting it
this is just getting annoying all this
like still stuff it's just it's I don't
like it so I'm gonna go over here that
was just used for when we were when I
was explaining you how it worked
let's just get scared
that so now that we've we've just got a
nice okay our consoles are all clean now
so it's all good okay so let's just go
ahead and just delete this wall crap and
come in here to render 3d so what this
wall thing was this this was just
basically a you know just like quick I
don't know like if that was just me
explaining you guys had to put pixels
onto the screen so now you guys don't
know how to do that let's actually make
solid like planes now instead of that
instead of that stuff that will actually
sort of a line without rotation so one
of the hardest thing things to do is
actually be rotation of walls because
when we rotate right and speaking of
rotation what I actually want to do is
I'll just come in here into we're not
using this anymore so let's just lay
this well we're out of clean up my card
let's say yeah all right instead of okay
instead of our rotation at the moment
because I don't want to do that where is
our rotation rotation let's just comment
that out and first of all let's just set
rotation to I don't know game belt time
we might we'll see what we'll see where
this gets us I don't know just off the
top of my head I just want to see how
that will okay no I didn't want to do
that math dots line okay
let's see how this war this will work
out
okay it's good so that's way too fast
ten maybe that's even faster all right
okay that's really slow all right forty
maybe not that much okay no right so
while you watch me helplessly trying to
make this look good
okay that's that'll be fine that's still
a bit too fast
I say while making it faster still
recovering so just hang in there all
right
that is nice okay cool yeah that's not
gonna okay that's fine okay so we'll
just keep it like this for now so we've
got basic rotation without us actually
needing to rotate the thing the screen
so that we can sort of work on these
awards while it's rotating okay but in
the meantime let's stop it so I'm going
to comment it up again and put it to
zero for the moment just so we can work
on a still sort of canvas alright so
let's get started with this so first
thing I want to do is let's just make a
new method here called and make it
public and we'll call it avoid it won't
return anything and we'll call it I
don't know we'll call it render wall
because that's what it's going to do and
we're like we're gonna make it take a
few parameters and double a few doubles
X left X right X and by X I mean like
the horizontal so like the left of the
wall the right of the wall basically the
left position of the ball the right
position of the wall the the the
distance I'm just gonna put that in
front of it because that is like the
distance and in the height so Y is high
all right so it's taking taking quite a
few parameters here let's terminate this
and go fullscreen yeah I forgot the
double
all right there we go so I just want to
say quickly before we jump right into
this this is going to be probably be
most complicated tutorial we've ever
done
okay and I swear if one of you people
asked me for the source code of this I
will not give it to you because you need
to understand what this does so just
take your time
this tutorial is probably gonna be like
40 minutes long unfortunately but that's
just probably inevitable I'm gonna try
and squeeze it into half now by not
talking like this aimlessly you need to
understand how this works
because it's really complicated okay I
actually took like four hour it took me
four hours to work out how to explain
this to you guys because it is
complicated
so before we actually just guests at
into the code I'm just gonna explain
these four variables that we've created
now if you don't know what parameters
are then you shouldn't be here you
should be on the new Boston's tutorials
learning how to learning Java basically
if you do know what parameters are
that's good so we've created four
parameters here they're all doubles and
the first one is X left now notice I use
X Z and Y okay I use basically in the
front of these of the names of these
variables I put letters and X as you
know is a horizontal axis Y is the
vertical axis and Z is the depth does
that axis it's the depth or the distance
whichever you prefer and basically we've
got sort of like this is like this
parameter is going to be the left of our
wall where the left of that wall is
located right it's X right it's gonna be
the right of our wall distance is gonna
be like if we check this out we've sort
of got like a block system going on here
this would be zero actually no this
would be zero this would be one this
would be true I don't know it actually
this is probably gonna be zero that's
probably gonna be 0.5 that's probably
gonna be one 31.5 but anyway you can you
can see
is sort of the further we go there the
further we go down this little path the
greater the distance is gonna be right
and minus one might be like you won't
see it because it'll be behind the
camera and height is gonna be like
basically what we achieved last time
when we sat on the walls as we measured
that this was two blocks high right
because this is like one block and it is
like the second block so this is two
blocks high so why height would be
either one or either zero or one
oh I don't know zero and zero point five
I don't know well we'll get on to
rendering it and we'll see what numbers
it takes so that's sort of what these
things are because we want to be able to
set these things outside of the render
wall thing all right
so let's let's just jump into this thing
so first of all first but a few things
we need to do is make some calculations
as to if we move so there's one like
there's one way of doing this which is
just draw a wall onto the screen and
then then there's the other thing
the other way of doing this which says
okay if we move like that walls
obviously knock on them like we don't
want the wall the wall to move with the
camera we want the wall to stay in its
geographical location even while we're
rotating even while we're moving around
in a pretty space okay so to do that we
need to calculate you know what happens
if we move right what happens if we move
forward what happens if we rotate so I'm
gonna say X C and the C here is gonna
stand for calculate so this is gonna be
the left calculation of the wall so okay
I don't know if I'm explaining this well
enough guys I'm gonna try my best
throughout this tutorial if you don't
understand something I don't know just
tell me let me know ultra I might try it
to explain this in a different method
maybe more concisely in the next episode
I don't know we'll see but in this
episode I really want to focus on
getting the code down as well as as well
as as well as explaining to you guys how
it works so so we're gonna take whatever
we input as left Bing I'm gonna subtract
it from right now right I'll get on to
this in a minute
and we'll multiply it by two now right
is actually referring to right so that's
basically what we've said is our
horizontal movement I don't know why we
called it right that's kind of stupid
but let's just call it live it is right
I guess for now but that's if we want to
move left or right so yeah the problem
here is that obviously it's it's inside
the floor method which isn't good so how
do you fix that you might be asked well
that's fine it's really easy to fix all
you have to do is basically we want to
make this global now last time you saw
that I sort of had like that I don't
know what it was something global equals
like I don't know you just probably saw
it now that's fine if you've got one
variable but as you can see we sort of
want to we'll one that we'll want to
access the forward variable the cosine
the sine variable because that's all the
rotation data that we actually need so
instead of actually you know doing that
we can just we can just make a thing off
the top here and say double private
double don't need to go private but it's
cool to do that
private double forward right rotation no
no we don't need rotation we need a
cosine and sine right so we're doing all
this stuff up here and now let's just
simply remove this stuff what else
cosine is sine and that's until we do
now we have access to those variables in
a different method so that's yeah you
could just do that so as you can see now
I think it's gone away and it's working
okay so the other thing we need to do is
the Z calculation for the left now the
way I want to do this and let me just do
this and this is gonna be our distance
so that was sort of the left of the like
the the actual horizontal data of where
it was this is like the Zed daughter of
where it is and you understand all this
when you once you see it on the screen
I'll sort of play around with it and
show you guys once they
whilst I finish typing the code all
right so let's just run this there won't
do anything obviously but that's what
I'm saying
you know like think of it as corners
that's what I'm doing right now I'm
basically drawing out four corners and
saying okay let's just fill the area
inside the corners but first of all
let's designate four corners so what
you'll see later actually what you'll
see oh my goodness well it's this
exception I don't know why it totally
just yeah it just crashed wow that's
weird okay well hope that doesn't happen
again anyway so what I want to do now is
I want to sort of do four corners so and
this is gonna basically okay this is
basically going to rely on our rotation
data that's why I've called it rot short
for rotation left side and X so we'll
see all this in a minute and there's
going to be sine times cosine minus said
see left and this is as you would expect
to make something able to rotate you
know you do this right so yeah I'm not
gonna even bother miscellaneous I'm
gonna sort of type all this up and then
I'll show you so this is gonna be the Y
corner so this is going to be like the
vertical so you can move a corner
basically two three ways right if you've
got a corner of like a block you can
move it depth wise you can move it up
and you can move it side to side that's
how you can move it right so TL is our
top left corner top left corner so it's
basically our top left corner of our
wall right and that's going to equal
minus y height and okay
- why hi - up and up and lost obviously
x - okay so up is one thing that we
figure out to actually define here up
all right so basically as you as you can
tell that's sort of like the Y the
vertical movement of the top left corner
right there and that's going to depend
on obviously where we decide to put our
wall and then we got the bottom left
corner so top left bottom left and we'll
do the right side in a minute let me
just get the left side down first we're
gonna do is add 0.5 here and you'll see
why in a minute like oh I'll subtract it
later on I've just I've already pre pre
calculated all these things so that I
wouldn't have to waste time here
freaking diagnosing it but you'll see
why I why I'm putting all these numbers
here in a minute actually in a minute I
say that it's actually gonna be in like
20 minutes
yeah I guess is that rotation to the
left side okay and same as last time
except obviously the inverse of that
being plus instead of minus and
switching they move them around so you
can skip that XC that's said see that's
that's a that's XE so we've sort of flip
these two around as we did for rotation
like we pretty much used this technique
before right over here it's the same as
this that for a wall all right so that's
all of our left side done let's do the
right side now so XC right so there's
calculations for the right side equals x
right which of course is our the
position of our right part of our wall
the right edge of our wall
and - right so if we decide to move
right if we decide to move horizontal
let it should stay
oh and okay yeah I'll say this in a
minute let me just finish this up double
zetsu right equals distance so we're
doing the same thing as we did here
except for the right side so yeah it
should be self-explanatory
- forward times - all right don't want
to we don't want to open any resources
and basically we're gonna have to have
to do this entire thing except to the
right side so I'm gonna retype this
obviously if I was not doing this for
you guys and if you guys doing this at
home I would copy and paste this
basically once you've typed this out
just copy and paste this area right here
and change the you know change the
numbers not the numbers but the variable
names because that's what you do in
programming you do that a lot
copy and paste code and change little
things and that's how you get a game
okay so write x cosine - said C write x
sine what I do here because that
obviously doesn't exist
I've put side X here by accident
okay what else is a our cornets that's
right corner now we got our top right
corner t our top right you could just
type that out if you like I just don't
want to type it out now yep my height
might have minus y height actually - up
and times - all right and we have to do
the same thing for our top left corner
which will be basically the same as the
other one you know 0.5 minus y hi
- up and times - alright now that seems
good top right
wait bottom right all right and our
final one is our rotation right sides
that yeah that's gonna equal the same
thing as the other thing except we're
replacing two variables we're not
putting eight we're putting x + XC right
times sign all right now that took a
while okay now we've got our basic
corner pins you could call them that if
you want now what we have to do is
basically you know compute all this into
a like a left pixel location and a right
pixel location so double x pixel left so
this is gonna be like basically out or
like our left edge and that's kind of a
cool make sure you get this right you
actually have to get everything right I
don't know you guys are gonna want to
copy and paste my source code but just
type it out you'll learn so much more
trust me
okay so let's look at this what we've
done is we've taken our our basic
rotation value and we pop we've popped
it in here we've divided it by the set
so that it rotates properly and hide
them with I've also been you know x and
added and divided by two to make it work
and we have to do the exact same thing
to the right side except surprise
surprise it's not rot left it's right
right beside X divided by right side Zed
and there's no like this will all make
sense in a minute in 20 minutes it's
probably about four ten minutes we'll
see all right so what a few things here
we've got our left pixel we've got like
our left edge of our wall and our right
edge of the wall now there's a few
things we have to account for here first
of all the first thing we're gonna sort
of handle I guess the first arrow
we're gonna handle is what if the left
side of our wall is somehow greater than
the right side of that writes out of our
wall so in other words paint.net is a
really good program seriously I'm
considering donating to them because
they've helped me a lot with slow
startup times okay all right
so if our wall is like this and then
like this is okay let's just speak to
this as as being our wall now I don't
think I can actually yeah
can I actually okay good I can so this
is our wall right what if we some reason
decide to basically we might not decide
this but for some reason like our left
side becomes greater than our right side
like what's going on there like that's
not gonna that's gonna generate negative
pixels and we don't want that to happen
so we want to say that if for some
reason the left side the value of this
the X like the horizontal coordinate of
this side of our wall is greater than
the right side of our wall well then
just get out of there so basically don't
render anything because it's obviously
wrong so in other words what I want to
say is if our X picks left is greater
than or equal to right so if it's the
same greater than or equal to X pixel
right so the our right side of that wall
just um return and general return means
return means get out of this method so
get out of the render wall method and
return back to doing whatever you were
doing so don't ignore all this stuff
that you've just done because we're
wrong somehow
all right the other thing when you do is
say okay well let's take a look at our
pixels right and so let's just make it
grid oh one quick thing I saw this in a
comment the other day it was a question
how do you get this grid thing this grid
thing is a plug-in for paint.net it does
not come with paint oh then it should
but it doesn't okay so if you want to
get this just Google like paint
red or something you should come up with
plugin page for paint on that because
you actually actually have to download
and install this plugin it's free
obviously but that's how you get the
grid alright so there's a pixels what we
have to work out is this this pixel
might be like 10 across right it's like
15 across but anyway this is like 10
across right so the problem here is this
current stuff like it's gonna generate
numbers that are doubles and we need
that for precision but on the other side
what but on the other hand we can't have
them as int as like II can't you can't
basically render a pixel it was like
just like this you know that's not gonna
work we need to sort of make these like
15 16 17 not like fifteen point two
three eight seven one you can't do that
you have to have you know you have to
have integers so what we need to do now
don't save what we need to do now is
actually convert our our computations
into integers now you don't want to do
that beforehand because otherwise it
just won't be accurate you want to sort
of deal with doubles as long as you can
you want to deal with decimals as long
as you can and then at the end if you
absolutely can't use the decimal for
some reason like pixels not being able
to have mid mid ways between pixels then
you're gonna have to convert it into
integer and that is obviously really is
it true so this is us converting our
expects a left into an integer I'm going
to call it X pixel left int right now I
hope I'm not naming these too
complicated this is the integer version
of this variable okay I hope you guys
getting this how do you convert a double
into it into an integer you do something
called a cast so you put a cast of an
INT in front of it and that's all you
have to do then you type the double you
want to convert into an integer and
you're done now I'm not going to copy
and paste this even though it's stupid
not to and I want to do the same thing
for the right so int X pixel
I can type I have my keyboard until out
because it's I got a new keyboard it's
mechanical
it's a razer blackwidow ultimate
battlefield 3 edition because they
didn't have the normal edition in stock
so I had to pay 15 bucks extra for the
for the battlefield 3 limited limited
edition which I'm not regretting it's
kind of a nice keyboard but uh it might
be a bit loud cuz it's mechanical anyway
enough about my keyboard and let's get
on to this alright other things we've
gone through this if the pixels are out
of the screen don't render them don't
waste resources computing where they are
just don't write at them so in other
words if our x pixel left int is greater
than or equal to sorry what am i doing
is less than zero we'll do the greater
than stuff later what am i doing okay so
if it's less than zero in other words if
it's like if it's out of the screen then
set it equal to zero so set it equal to
the screen don't let it go negative
because you don't need it to go navigate
negative that will just waste resources
and same thing exactly the same thing
for the right area
now how why it is our screen at the
moment it's 800 pixels now if we change
that later we don't want to have to
change this so with that's how wide it
is so again X pixel right equals bit
simple yet effective alright let's make
summer meal
sorry we're about halfway through this
this computation will really complicated
stuff and now what we have to do is
actually make the four corner pins so
got to make four doubles fresher them
we're going to call on Y pixel left top
so this is going to be left in the top
corner of our thing and we're gonna cast
us into an int now even though it's
double pay attention even though with
the double we're gonna cast it into an
int and you'll see why in a minute we
could actually have this as an int but
I'm just gonna leave it as a double for
now so we've got our Y corner
top left which is here so we're grabbing
that we're gonna divide that by our
rotation left side Z said we're gonna
multiply that by our height and we're
gonna add height and then / - right so
it's going to basically what it's going
to do is it's gonna divide a it's gonna
divide Y corner by variation left side
then what its gonna do is it's gonna
multiply that number by the height and
then it's going to divide height by two
so make that what is Heidi summers make
that 300 and then compute this and then
add 300 to it so that is what's going on
here keep in mind there are any brackets
around this so it's not doing hi
people's height then / - it's doing
height divided by two plus whatever this
is that's important basic maths are in
bod mass brackets I don't remember what
Bob master oh but um you know the
multiplication and division comes before
addition and subtraction all right sir
left bottom and again we're going to
cause that into an end and make this the
bottom left / left side Z so the same
thing that we did last time again x
height added to height divided by two
and well where that come from capslock
rage double y pixel right top is gonna
equal int y corner top right / right
side said x
Heights I'm sorry this is boring but
that's a 3d game programming in Java for
you can be boring at times I'm trying to
work out how walls work
/ - and finally that's which one's left
so we've done left top left bottom right
top never gonna do right bottom it's
alright bottom equals cost hint y corner
bottom right so it's top left left top
I've actually probably should have
called them top left top right but
anyway top left bottom left left bottom
double right right top bottom right
right bottom suffix binary I hope sides
said what are we done TARDIS buy a
height add height / - okie dokie now now
what we have to do now is we've computed
every single piece of information
possible almost actually but we've done
we've done most of the work here so what
we have to do now is what's the problem
here sit down on this thing figure out
the bracket here what we have to do now
is sort of make a full loop to render
this now it's not really a full loop
okay it's like a trick sort of thing and
I'll show you guys why so for in x
equals x so we're not saying x equals
zero we're saying x equals the expec
select int and as long as it's basically
less than this X pixel right int then X
plus plus so as you can see this is this
is interesting so what is saying is it
saying that let's set X equal to
location the left side of our wall and
say that if it's less than the right
side of the wall if X is like so if X
pixel left in is less than right side
right side of the wall then keep on keep
on rendering so basically if we have an
inverted
the wall keep on rendering it and keep
on moving it depending on of course on
you know on the location of our player
so if we rotate rotate with the wall so
double pixel rotation equals X minus X
pixel left and we're going to divide
that by our right stuff so right and -
left right so we're working out rotation
data here X pixel top the Y pixel top
rather it's gonna be Y pixel left top
plus y pixel right top - I hope this
table is not too loud by the way if it
is telling me I might get a quieter one
just for these tutorials I might use my
old one that's what I meant
all right - y pixel left top and times
pixel rotation which we just did there
and one more for our bottom like this is
fairly like okay so we've done that our
left and right now we've got to do the
top and bottom suppose that we've done
the left and right sides of our wall now
we have to do the top and bottom of our
wall bottom equals y pixel left bottom
and again the way we're going to do that
is when we're gonna sort of get these
four corners and turn them up so join
them up in surgery thinking of surgery
I've been watching a lot of house lately
so yeah fantatic show house m.d.
Doctor of Medicine so yeah it's a great
show if you're considering watching it
watch it as brilliant
it's the first three seasons off because
that's where I'm up to halfway
no really halfway through about episode
5 of season Fraser I'm up to anyway so
we've we've we've done the top and
bottom now so all we have to do now is
sort of well do the same thing that we
did last time I mean we converted the
left and right into integers now let's
do the else convert the top and bottom
into integers so why pixel top int
equals the end cost of a pixel it's like
7 or 9 p.m. I'm kind of tired that's all
that's why I'm taking this slow okay
this is yes this is gonna be our longest
story ever I'm taking a while to upload
if I can get it tonight this is not top
anymore it's just bottom isn't it yes
it's bottom int that is then cast off
why pixel up of why pixel bottom
I forgot the nice bracket all right I
think that's just about it and obviously
as we did here we're gonna do the same
thing for our height so if well if our Y
pixel top int is less than 0 so if it
goes out of the frame top wise then set
it equal to 0 equals 0 and if our Y
pixel top end is greater than our height
then set it equal to height what's
height simple as that
all right now we've done everything
basically now all we have to do is
actually render that so we have to
basically pop all these things into our
into our pixels into our pixel thing
which renders everything so for int y
equals y pixel top int under this is
launch toriel guys I try to make this as
short as possible seriously but wait I
can't just you know right off his card
and then continue with another episode
because I know you guys want to say
salt in the episode that you're watching
and again we're gonna open up that array
of pixels and we'll give it a color oh
by the way this like this color thing
like it's after you put the 0x it can be
any color and I'm sure if you open up
your browser and type in let me just put
up pop it onto the screen and type in a
hex color then there's a color picker
calm go to color picker calm and
whatever you see here so let's just pick
like a nice sort of blue color it looks
nice this you can take this number you
can pop it here and the pixels will the
world will be that will be that color
okay
like people were asking me how to change
like colors and stuff that's how you do
it you get the hex of the color so you
pick a color here or whatever this is
just really convenient cuz it really
simple and a lot of white space and it
just shows you what the color is so
we'll deal with this cough now looks
like it and we also need to do the
z-buffer computation so plus y times so
same thing times width equals zero
alright let's check this out okay so now
we've a lot of fun so it's like a little
like 70 lines of 60 lines of code sixty
three lines of code exactly actually so
that was a huge oh okay let's actually
say this works first
so render dart render wool and so we've
got our left so let's just set left
equal to like 0 will make right 1 will
make the distance to maybe 1 put the tip
now and we'll make our height 0 and
let's run this and see what it gives us
alrighty fantastic so check this out
we've got a wall here that's too length
as you can see if we probably flip
others to one actually what is this
all righty hang on a minute apparently
can't take one Vista - I don't know what
that is actually have forgotten the
order of things here all right so you
can see the basically what we've created
here is a nice wall and you can see that
our frame rate is we'll colossal it's
basically the same as it was before so
that's awesome now we're at 38 minutes
in this tutorial and Jason dressed for
this up I don't know
yeah here's what I'm gonna do what I'm
gonna do right now is I'm gonna not play
with this card okay I've shown you guys
this I'm gonna do one more thing and I
want to end this episode and then next
episode which will come maybe halfway
through the week I don't know who won't
be a an Express episode obviously might
be like a 20 minute episode or actually
explain and play around with these walls
that well things and show you guys what
we've actually done with the card and
how its how it's working but I don't
think I want to fit that in now because
this is a 39 minutes 30 seconds it's
huge I don't want to upload something
that big and expect and expect you guys
to watch someone sitting so uh yeah all
right so copy down that code and okay so
what's the order of things here okay so
we've got our left and our right here
right that's probably the problem our
second variable yeah okay so it looks
like that is one length of it so if we
go to screen then if we put this great
that's right oh we are we are a screen
okay if we put 0.5 here it should uh yep
there we go so we've got one thing here
now - what is - because I don't let us
crash last time that sounds that
distance strange we couldn't put it to
one because we are one that's probably
wine okay
yes everything is in 0.5 lengths that's
fine I really mind so like 1.5 yeah 1.5
works all right and this is our height
so put us to 1 loads I think 0.5 then
yeah that'll put it up there
similarly we can duplicate this method
obviously and put this to like zero and
we can create this as you can see
there's no drop in framerate I say that
as a drops two frames but point is like
there's no there's a minimal drop a
frame rate like there's none so that's
awesome and again you want another color
what do you want like a green grab this
hex pop it in here and look at that
magically it manages changed from the
same color is this colors amazing that's
not the point there I actually like the
blue more so I'm gonna get back to blue
all right
tennis a nice blue isn't it I'm very
good at picking clot colors okay so
that's how it works
one more thing though before I finish
this up is let's check out how it works
with the rotation it crashes it's how it
works the rotation all right that's not
good
okay array index out of bounds yeah as I
expected it to
okay that's fine that's no biggie we
might fix that next next episode we'll
see all right where is our rotation will
disable it from now all right so for the
winter in the meantime we've got this
awesome thing and that's about it you
know we've created this like the swole
thing which will actually work with
rotation hang on I don't want to I don't
want to in this episode now let me just
um hmm all right where is our runner
three days right here so
hmm all right sir before we go let's
just check out the rotation because I
really want to make sure it works
okay that's actually what is this hat
right now
okay let's take it off that will make it
about 40 right by 80 what's up here
multiply it by like 0.5 all right
so oh I see what's happening okay so
we've got a bit of a problem here
it's almost working that's the good news
yeah it's pretty much working we've got
a few issues it looks like at the right
corner pin if you watch that first of
all there seem to be two of them for
some reason but the third thing is the
first thing is rather auction I just got
it out as well we didn't need that
anyway hang on let's go into screen and
actually just render one of them all
right ha ha all right
so let's pop this down to ground floor I
think this is it all right so our
problem is that our our right thing
doesn't really work our right corner pin
seems to move so let's come in here into
render 3d and our right corner pin is a
bottom right it's a bottom right our top
right all right so the moment what's
happening is it's sort of not working
here and it's crashing here and that's
not good and it first of all it's
telling me here that um also it's not
that it's telling me it's just it's
showing to me that something's wrong
with the right side because you can see
that the left side stays perfectly put
into that place except for the right
side which doesn't work obviously
there's something wrong here
and I want to say that it's gonna be on
right-side rotation somewhere so
rotation left side rejection right side
oh look at that
I put an equal sign here instead of
instead of a mole I put two of them
there actually that should not be a
battery Wow
all righty now there's still another one
there but we fixed the primary error
which was that there just happens to be
an element if for some reason it's like
what we're rendering to or something
that is weird but that one works that
one causes the crash so that's kind of
weird
you